hi there today we'll look at an image is
worth
16 by 16 words transformers for image
recognition
at scale so this paper is a bit special
andrei carpathi
tweeted this out and i'm going to guess
many of you have
seen it already it's a paper that's
under review
at iclear iclear of course uses open
review
so all these submitted papers can be
seen and
can technically be commented on and
as you can see it's anonymous and good
thing it's anonymous because the
double-blind review process
relies on anonymity so we can really
evaluate this paper uh which is a very
interesting paper at its
merits without you know having a clue
who would be writing something like this
now out of pure out of pure
randomness i just happen to have this in
my like
uh ctrl c ctrl v
memory i just pasted this here i don't
know why but this is this other paper
called big
transfer uh general visual
representation learning
by alexander koleznikov lucas perez
yahwah
chai and others of google research i've
actually made a video about this so if
you're
interested totally not related at all
um i mean yeah so disregard
the fact that the paper that we're
discussing here uses a
gft 300m data set that is not available
to the public
only to google that is um
[Music]
and actually this other paper also
trains on that
disregard that um also largely disregard
the fact
that their model is called vit
while the other papers model is called
bit
disregard the fact that they
train on the exact same data sets as you
can see
right here i mean this here is imagenet
then c for 100
pets flowers and the v tab v tab this
visual task adaptation benchmark i've
done a video on that too
by google but they do have actually
the imagenet reel here which is a just a
set of new labels for imagenet
which comes out of a paper by google
with largely the same
authors as this paper i mean disregard
the fact that
the color scheme for the vtab evaluation
is exactly the same as is the histogram
plotting and of course we don't even
want to bicker about
the plotting style with these uh bubble
sizes and so i mean anyone could do this
anyone anyone in the world
could just randomly have this much
overlap
with these models and of course anyone
just
has the money laying around to train on
2.5
000 tpu v3 days
um and you know compared with 9.9
000 tpu v3 days for the bi team
i guess you could just pick those
numbers out of the paper but what do i
know
um so
no don't worry peer review is totally
fine like like
i mean yeah so i hope i've made my point
this is by these people
um and
you know people say you know we need
anonymous on
on archive because the danger is that
people upload their paper and archive
and then we can see
who they are i think this should prove
to anyone that
an anonymous archive is like it's the
crappiest why
why like why would you ever
work against the core incentives of
people like clearly these authors have
an incentive to make
known who they are and clearly we as
readers have an incentive to figure
it out and to completely work against
these incentives just seems so
it seems dumb it seems counterproductive
and it doesn't
work as you can see what do you want to
do standardize
the plotting styles standardize
everything
standardize the citations i mean come on
here
you go like when we compare oh no
um where is it
when the when they compare against
things they say
oh our first point of comparison our
first coin point of comparison
is the big trend randomly just big
transfer
by these authors that we have no
relation to maybe or maybe not um
it's it's ridiculous you can't shield
this this fake anonymity um this is
actually counterproductive and it only
helps
the big labs um the this anonymity
criterion
all right let's actually dive into the
paper after this rant
well yeah don't worry peer review very
pristine very good
very anonymous double blind for sure
so the paper says while the transformer
architecture has become the de facto
standard for natural language processing
tasks and we know this you know
this is from the first attention is all
you need paper
two things like bert gpt gpt2
gpt3 transformers have revolutionized
nlp say its applications to computer
vision
remain limited envision attention is
either applied in conjunction with
convolutional networks
or used to replace certain components of
while keeping their overall structure in
place which is correct in
computer vision convolutional networks
have been so incredibly
successful uh since alexnet and then of
course
resnets uh being the major contributor
there i mean even this big transfer
paper right here all it does is
scale up resnets and then feed in more
data
so cnns are extremely extremely powerful
in computer vision we show that this
reliance on cnns is not necessary
and a pure transformer can perform very
well
on image classification tasks when
applied to when applied
directly to sequences of image patches
and they go on saying that
they outperform cnns while
requiring substantially fewer
computational resources to
train well you know substantially fewer
in these regimes
of thousands of tpu days is you know
something that
um is a bit ironic honestly
but you know it's it's it's it's pretty
cool
so what's the deal with transformers and
images
uh classically transformers are of
course things
models that operate on the sequences
specifically actually they operate on
sets
so you'd have a set of words uh which
you can characterize as tokens which i'm
just going to characterize
as bubbles and then the transformer
would somehow
take all of these in and do
something with them and something in
this particular case
is attention and the tension is a
quadratic operation
which basically means that you have to
calculate
the pairwise inner product between each
of these between each pair of the
of these bubbles which becomes a very
very large task very quickly you see i
even have trouble
drawing i think i drew this twice
however this
this already with five it it is many
many many interconnections and you can
imagine that if you are in nlp and have
a paragraph that's maybe
500 tokens long you need 500 squared
connections so
this one uh thing is a limitation of
transformers they work
really really well for nlp however
they are limited by the memory and
compute requirements
of that quadratic attention
images are therefore much harder for
transformers because an
image of course is a raster of pixels
and there are many many many many pixels
to an image right so usually even in
so imagenet might be imagenet counts as
a
large images in computer vision
applications but even the image net
they're like what 250 by 250 pixels
which are small by human standards we
are used to looking at
i don't know 1 000 or 2000 pixel um
side length on a regular basis
for for it to be clear i mean even the
rasterization of this pdf you can see
is you you will recognize it as blurry
um
and that's that's way way more
resolution
than imagenet images so the
just the rasterization of images is a
problem
in itself even for convolutional neural
networks
but if you want to feed this into a
transformer
you have to think that every single
location here every single pixel has to
attend
to every single other pixel
which the image itself is 250
squared
big so the attention will cost you 250
squared which is impossible in current
hardware even for google
right maybe they can do it but
so people have resorted to other things
uh doing things like only
local attention so only attending to the
kind of area
around them which of course is the the
foundational
motivation behind convolutional neural
networks is that
you learn kernels that are local and
then
you you kind of slide them across and
over the layers
across layers once once you go from
layer to layer so
the first layer this part might attend
to
like a cone around itself and this part
might
attend around a cone around itself but
then the next layer the thing that
attends
in the same cone will have a larger
effective
receptive field right so in this the
receptor field grows
by depth however transformers are able
to attend
within a single layer to everywhere
and this paper solves this by not going
in the direction of hey let's do
local attention over pixels but they say
let's do global attention
by simply going over image patches
so they divide the image into these
patches
as you can see here and one patch is in
this case
something like 16 by 16.
they unroll these patches into a
sequence which
is a in first instance it's a set
they combine this with a positional
embedding so
the transformers naturally they have no
idea
what what is where it's not like
the transformer in a way is a
generalization of an mlp of a
feed-forward network in a feed-forward
network
what you have is you have
you have just you have connections
between
these different inputs and outputs okay
and these are fixed
so the this node here will always attend
to this node here with the weight that's
specified by this particular connection
however in a transformer this w
isn't a fixed number in a transformer
this w
is computed on the fly so
and and that's dependent on what these
exact nodes
are and therefore the m while the mlp
knows where information comes from the
transformer doesn't the transformer
computes on the fly and therefore is
permutation and variant
and that's why a lot of applications add
to the inputs these so-called positional
embeddings
where they simply say look this here
this here is patch number one this here
is patch number two this here is patch
number three
and you can do this in a sophisticated
way in images
specifically you can say this is
position one one this is position one
two one three then you go on by saying
this is two one
two two and so on now they in the paper
claim that they've tried this and it
doesn't help
it's it's uh much easier if they just
say this is one two
three four five and uh the
these are learnable embeddings so the
the you don't actually feed the number
one but what you have is you have a
table
and the table will say we'll have these
indices one two three four five and so
on
and each one is associated with a vector
and these vectors are
learnable parameters so whenever you say
this is the first patch what you
actually do is you go here
you grab the vector to the number one
and you put the vector
along sorry up here along
with the patch into the transformer
now the patch itself is still a small
image right it's a 16 by 16 image
so you have to get that somehow into a
form where the transformer can
understand it
one way of doing it of course is simply
to unroll it and say
gee this is a 16 by 16 what's what's 16
by 16 it's
like 256 um
i think so i don't know
i guess two it's 250 it's a 256
dimensional
vector however
they find that if they that first put
that through a linear
projection that helps before they put it
into a transformer so there is
one single matrix and this one single
matrix is called
e in this case embedding haha
they take a patch like this
they unroll it so here you have the
image you unroll it into a big vector
you multiply that vector with the
embedding matrix and
that's what goes into the transformer
along with the position embedding in
this case we have position embedding
whatever
seven you go grab seven right here
you concatenate that here or add it
and you put that into the transformer
and from here it's a
standard transformer this is just out of
attention is all you need
standard transformer and what you do
is you have a special input this is a
learnable embedding
it's like the birth embedding the cls
embedding and
you take the output of this thing
finally
in order to classify this is just a
standard classifier so it's a really
simple architecture except for the
bottom part here
it's a transformer one of the inputs is
decided to be
special that is not associated with any
patch but is a learned input
the output of that particular dimension
or of that particular input you take as
a classification
okay so there are more outputs right
here but they
are discarded of course because so in
the last layer they're actually not even
computed i would guess
what in the last layer only this thing
is computed but in the other layers
everything is always computed right so
you have many many transformer
layers in here transformer layers are of
course made up
from these blocks right here sorry not
the embedded patches but
this thing
okay and you see the the multi-head
attention that's the expensive
operation so the paper completely
completely discards the notion of
convolutions
they have a variant where they i believe
replace this patch embedding here
with a convolutional embedding
but i don't i don't think it helps much
they they really want to show that
convolutions aren't
necessary and i i don't want to go too
much into the
details of the paper because also it's
it's also subject to change you know an
open review
you can revise it and so on uh but the
experiments show as you can see
right here that this visual transformer
this vision transformer
outperforms uh the the the
other like the convolutional networks by
a pretty significant amount often
like sometimes small but sometimes also
large
and costs less to train than these big
convolutional networks
at least of of this one other paper
right
so it costs less to train here you see
of course if you go
16 by 16 patches
then that means you will have so if you
divide your
image into patches that are themselves
bigger that means
your your sequence of patches will
become smaller and therefore
you're computationally more efficient if
you go
with 14 by 14 patches um but also the
the h i believe is more layers
uh there is actually a table up here
yeah so the huge
has 32 layers and
that is has doubled the amount of
parameters
all of that gives you a higher
computational requirement
still lower than the big transfer paper
okay so the idea here is you train on
these big
data sets like this jft data set so you
pre-train
on that this is a weakly labeled data
set of
300 million images and then you transfer
to the other data sets
which just happened to be the same data
sets that this paper used plus the other
data set that the same authors created
after this paper came out
don't worry about it okay they also test
on this
visual task adaptation benchmark and you
can see that especially
specifically in these natural images
subclass they oh
actually both of these models make gains
but
then overall the visual
transformer outperforms the conf nets
so what's the what's the deal here
what's the deal with transformers and
that's something i want to talk about i
don't want to go
too much into the rest here of course
you can visualize the attention you can
see it's doing
something sensible um and you can
visualize the positional embeddings that
are learned which is pretty interesting
and you can see that
uh the position embeddings come out
pretty sensible you can see
where they pay attention to mostly and
the
seems like this positional embedding it
largely recognizes
where it is in the image even though you
never tell it you simply let it learn
but it it relates to other positional
embeddings that are in the same row or
column largely and that's all sensible
you can see the filters it learns
so this is analogous to visualizing what
convolutional networks learn and you can
see it does
something sensible it does something
that we're very much used to if you look
at convent visualizations you'll see
exactly filters like these
so it learns almost like the same
thing as convolutional neural networks
right but it's not specifically
programmed to do so
also you can see as you increase the
depth of the network
the mean attention distance so the the
distance
over which the attention uh goes
increases and from like the middle of
the network you
pretty much have global computation and
this is also
like this is almost like the drawing i
made of the cnn right where
you you would have um the different
heads so some heads would
immediately at the beginning go out
a cnn in this case would look like a
line
a cnn would look like a line that's like
this
the additional benefit you get in the
transformers is of course that at the
very beginning
you can already pay attention to things
that are very far away
you cannot do that with convolutional
networks or when you use local attention
so all this branch
up here that's kind of the gain that
transformers
can make they can attend to very far
away things right at the lower layers
um yeah so so what's the deal with
transformers it seems like transformers
are coming
for everything so first they i guess
they
they were attention was introduced in
lstms
so lstms with attention were the cool
thing to do
and i think still are in some places in
nlp um but then transformers completely
replacing
lstms in nlp and now transformers are
coming
for vision they have been paired with
vision as the introduction here said
but now they are replacing convolutions
sorry they've been paired with
convolutions now they're replacing it
and here's what i what i think about
this
so what you had in lstms
and in convolutional neural networks
were
good inductive priors
so technically if you think about it if
you have something like
an mlp a feed forward network like we
looked at here
the the the notion should be
that it could technically learn any
function right
a feedforward network can technically
learn any function
but it's it's kind of unstable and so on
you know if you shift by a pixel all the
inputs are all weird and so on so a
convolutional neural network for images
seemed pretty good because it has a good
inductive prior
and the good inductive prior is this is
that probably what
a one pixel cares about is its immediate
neighborhood
and then what that neighborhood as a
whole cares about
is its immediate neighborhood right so
that's sort of how we look at images
like you integrate
over small regions and then you connect
the regions to each other and so on so
this is a very sensible
inductive prior for images as well as
the lstm for language if you have a
language
right having an lstm having the
inductive
bias of let's first process this thing
then you know remember some general woo
state then in in go to this thing
and then incorporate that into our
memory what we already know
right then that kind of updates our
latent belief
and then we go to this thing and again
we uh incorporate that that's how we
read
and that's that's how we do it and so
the inductive prior of this model
is is actually very very solid and
inductive
priors or inductive biases
uh the name already contained it it's a
bias
we bias the model towards solutions that
we think
in general are relevant are are useful
right we we we tell the model look
we know you could learn everything from
data
no doubt about it we have the
theoretical results you could do that
however you don't have enough data and
we want to make it a bit easier for you
so we tell you
that certain things like cnns like
convolutions
generally tend to be useful
so we restrict the model and we bias the
model towards
a certain solution or lstms these
are bias biases that we introduce in the
statistical sense of bias right so
these are biases that help the model
become very good at tasks however now we
are in a regime
where we have lots of data and
lots and lots of data and we know bias
why is it called bias
because it will buy us our estimator our
estimator
will not be the perfect
expect expected value matches the actual
underlying thing
estimator therefore
we know that if we have enough data a
biased model
will perform worse in the end than an
unbiased model
it's only in the not enough data limit
that the bias model can
perform uh better at least i mean i'm
simplifying here but
now transformers come along and
transformers are basically
transformers aren't an another
architecture transformers are basically
a general compute
thing they're even more general than
mlps like people think that mlps like
this
mlps are the the on
most unbiased thing ever because
everything's connected to everything no
transformers are actually
more general because not only is
everything connected to everything but
these connections are always computed
on the fly so a transformer is like the
most
general thing there is in terms of deep
learning that we have right now
that we can train um
yeah i'm making bold statements but
that's how i think about it
so the the if the cnn and the lstm
are more specialized mlps then the
transformer is a less specialized mlp
and therefore it's not necessarily in
the architecture of the transformer
that makes it so special it's just the
fact that it is a general
computer and if we we are now
able to feed enough data into it such
that
it can actually learn the the things and
it can
it can not only can it learn the useful
biases right we give
we give useful biases and you can see it
learns the same thing as a convolutional
network or very similar things right it
learns
these filters and so on that before we
would have
we would have given this thing here as
like a wavelet filter
that was our even before cnn's we we fed
in like wavelet filtered
things and this thing would be on top of
the list so it learned it can learn that
from scratch
but probably this thing is not exactly a
wavelet filter
it's actually something that performs
slightly better right
that we couldn't have come up with as a
as a bias to build in
and that's why it works better because
it can
learn almost the same things but it can
do so a bit better because it has
that much data so
i believe the world is still open
transformers aren't
the end transformers are simply one
general computer
there can be others there can be
something even more general than a
transformer and
their world is still wide open to
build in inductive biases that are
actually better than
cnns or lstms also to build inductive
biases in transformer
or if you go in the other direction to
alleviate because what you see
right here and in the formula you see
this pretty well
there are inductive biases in the
transformer
and if i had to guess i would say
the ones that are to go next are the
skip connections in here
now the skip connections are very
important for us to
be able to train these uh architectures
um because if you read the resonant
paper
the residual nets paper that's kind of
where the gradient flows back the
rationale is
that you can go very deep and each layer
only has to kind of
calculate the delta that you have to do
to the
input instead of transforming the input
as such and so on it makes
a lot of sense but it is a strong
inductive bias
and it pulls through all of the layers
as you can see here right
all of like the skip connections is
pulled through all of the layers
this is a very strong inductive bias and
we tell the network maybe it's sensible
if you only calculate the diffs in each
layer
if i had to guess this is one of the
next
big things to go if we have
yet an order of magnitude more
big data sets and we figure out how to
train
big networks without these skip
connections
all right so it's not like as i said
it's not like transformers
is like the very very good architectures
in the same sense that lstms and cnns
are very good architectures
it is the fact that transformers are so
general
they are actually able to make use of
the big data that we just
now have that we didn't have before end
of the big compute
such that these inductive biases of the
old models become
unnecessary again
totally random i mean check out this
video if you're in the mood for a
totally random
absolutely non-related paper to this
tell me
what you think in the comments and
definitely you know keep an eye on this
on open review it's going to be
very very interesting all right with
that being said that was it from me
bye bye